[Music]
this week on book notes part one of a
two-part interview with author simon
seabag montefiore he joins us to discuss
his book stalin the court of the red
czar
[Music]
simon sebag montefiore author of stalin
i read an article about you were you
actually you wrote it and you said i be
i became so immersed in this world that
i had nightmares writing this book and
now on publication they have only just
stopped and i know this was publicized
over a year ago in england uh
nightmares why stalin was always stein
was always obsessed with um how people
behaved at the supreme moment
execution
and though he never attended any
uh torture any um any executions himself
he always wanted to know
how did they how did they behave at the
supreme moment and
so obviously i had to pay attention to
some of the stories of how people
behaved as they were about to be shot
and some were brave some some spat at
their executioners some died praising
stalin
and some just lost it and and um wept
and kissed the boots of their um
executioners
and um of course this this entered my
mind as did all of this stuff i mean
this whole weird world entered my mind
and i began to have nightmares about it
throughout the writing of this book i
have to admit i lost track through the
book there's so many names so many
stories what
how did you
you set it up when you went into it so
that you could keep track of all this
well
you know what i wanted to do was show
star in in a completely new light and in
fact you know some of some some
reviewers have said and that they've got
the point that this is the first
intimate biography of stalin and his and
his people around him and that that's
what it is i mean um it's it's it's
intimate it's private um it's the it's
the inner circle it's the inner world i
mean we never knew any of this stuff
before and i must say the result
is unsettling it's
it's a picture of it's a chronicle of
like debauchery depravity sadism murder
luxury power privilege um and these were
really the most diabolical people ever
to run a country except the nazis i
think
i want to show a picture of nadja stalin
and ask you
who she was
and how many wives does dawn have yeah
um
nadya was stalin's much younger wife um
30 years younger than him
and um there she is um uh on her death
bed
and she was um she was the child of
bolshevik a bolshevik family stalin may
well have had an affair with her mother
um
it um when she was three years old and
started had known her for all her life
obviously except after she was three he
was said to have um
rescued her from
from from drowning as a child
when did she die she died in 1932 the
8th of november and she committed
suicide
how
it was on the evening of a great party
and the bolsheviks were great partiers
they had a great party at the
vorashilov's flat a flat in the kremlin
and afterwards she argued to star in she
went out she went back to her flat and
she shot herself with a pistol
and um and no one found it till morning
and when stalin was was was was informed
he was absolutely polaxed by it
how long had they been married um
they've been married for 2012 years or
so just over since since 1918
and what was the difference in age about
25 30 years and
what was the relationship like
it was like it was a mosaic of like
misery
um she was a schizophrenic she had
psychological problems and he was of
course impossible rough
egocentric so like moments of great
happiness and we have all the love
letters in the book which are
fascinating and that's one of the great
things about this treasure trove of
material in which the book's based
and other times you know great
unhappiness great happiness
great love
and also sort of um a rising um a rising
disquiet
leading to this tragic end his first
marriage first marriage kato's finishing
young educated girl georgian dies after
just two years of marriage of
tuberculosis
he afterwards says i'll never recover
from this my stony heart
will never recover will be cold forever
and
did he marry again yeah he then he
married nadia i mean but after that no
there was a lot of stories that he
married a jewish wife the the sister of
um kaganovich one of his closest um
closest colleagues who was jewish and it
was put around by the nazis but in fact
he was surrounded by jewish women you
know throughout the um 30s but he didn't
marry again he started an affair with
his sister-in-law after nadia's death
and when that finished he then began a
secret affair with his housekeeper
velechka
how was it secret and when did you find
out about it well that's fascinating i
mean no one had really no one really
found out much about valechika but in
fact she was a smiling
easygoing
very discreet peasant woman who um who
adored stalin and she looked after
stalin's um she all his appetites his
daughter said she looked after his
cooking she looked after her she folded
up his underwear which he was very proud
of he liked everything kept very tidy
she ironed his tunics and she was always
smiling and she never discussed politics
with him unless he asked her and there
were various moments in the history of
this story this amazing
country when she he did actually consult
velechka
for example when he was about to leave
moscow in uh october 1941
great mo decisive moment of the war
and a moment which could have changed
the whole history of our time um he said
to her what do the common people say
electrical whatever one's saying should
we leave moscow she said absolutely not
she said and that was made an impression
on him but of course the irony was that
when when churchill and people like that
were with stalin they were meeting with
stalin and this girl this sort of buxom
peasant woman came in in her white uh
tunic serving the food none of them
realized that this woman was stalin's
secret mistress
you say in one of the footnotes that she
never talked about it she never talked
about it she never spoke but when one
looked into it and i interviewed many of
the people i interviewed virtually
everyone alive um who knew stalin
intimately um including some of the top
officials who were still alive and of
course all of them remembered her and
knew about this
they said to me stalin didn't have a
private life um he was a public figure
but when you started to talk to them
about it and that was the official sort
of communist line of course which was
rubbish um but when you actually went
further than that and you you penetrated
and you got a trust they would remember
valencia and talk about valencia she was
quite a character
by the way at this stage if you had to
write another book
off of one of the characters in this one
who would you pick would have to be
barrier
um berry is the most fascinating i mean
after stalin barry was the most gifted
the most gifted of these people and the
most appalling i mean he was just a
diabolical figure um
uh super intelligent a brilliant manager
and his daughter-in-law who was one of
the people who had never been
interviewed before who i found she um
she uh famous she said that
if barry had come to america he'd have
risen to be chairman of general motors
which is interesting i think we have a
picture of him we'll put it on the
screen uh
what was he like there he is um he was
um coarse which one is he he's the one
on the right holding his hat that's
typical barrier um while molotov who's
in the middle is wearing um looks like a
clark on wall street um barry on the
right looks like a southern sort of
italian wine grower and he's that he
always wore um no tie
soft hat and um he's pretty fat and um
he wears pin snares glinting in the sun
and there he is visiting berlin right at
the end of the war triumphant visit um
he was a pervert of course a rapist
someone who drove the streets of moscow
in his black limousine um picking up
girls sending his bodyguards to pick up
girls which whom he raped um how do you
know that um we've talked to a lot of
them and um we found a lot of them and
um
of course when they said they were raped
this is one of the interesting things
the secret police chiefs had a special
sort of power over life and death and
they could say um you know your father's
in prison if you don't want him shot
perhaps you'd like to do something for
me
and so there were great debauches these
people i mean he was pre-epic he was
obsessed with women he caught vd tw
twice during the war and um which was
great embarrassment of course but stalin
heard about it um he was um he was he
was a sadist personally he would torture
people himself was very creative about
it when he heard that one woman um uh
hated snakes he had snakes put in her
cell um he was a great poison i had
people poisoned he belonged in the
history of the borders and yet he was
super capable super intelligent um
nothing was beyond his capabilities um
he was quite educated he was an
architect and he was a lovely sort of
father and um and husband and and and
also father-in-law and you know i'm very
lucky that i managed to find one of the
great contributors to this book is his
daughter-in-law who lived in his house
with him um and for eight years and so
knew him very well what's her name she's
called martha peshkova she's also gorky
maxim gorky's granddaughter so she knew
stalin from childhood then she was
svetlana stalin's um best friend then
svetlana stalin was in love with
berrier's son
and um wanted to marry him but martha
pishkova
did marry him and join the berrier
family and of course part of this i've
got to know the burial grandchildren and
great grandchildren so i know the
berrier family not something i ever
thought i'd boast of but you know
fascinating people and you can see from
that how incestuous this little world
was what a bizarre tiny little world of
seething hatreds um incestuous
relationships this was
barrier did what what was his highest
rank and um he was politburo member he
was secret police chief from 1938. first
of all he ran georgia in the 30s which
was the sort of um the country on the um
on the black sea where stalin came from
part of the soviet union um and then he
was promoted um to um in 1938 to be head
of the dreaded secret police and then he
became a really fearsome character i
mean people were terrified of him um he
continued the terror
he was he was a brilliant administrator
of terror um and he later he ran the
nuclear bomb
um administration so it was thanks to
him that the soviet union got the a-bomb
and of course that was his huge
contribution to history and he knew that
he knew if he failed as well he might
well lose his head for it where did you
find martha peshkova
all of them were through sort of friends
of friends of friends this little world
of
families that knew stalin is still
intact and they all still know each
other
and it's very hard to get to them i mean
some of them are quite well known
there are various ones who appear in
every documentary but the really
interesting ones have never really
spoken before and i had to win their
trust
and that's quite a difficult thing to do
and but gradually i went from one to the
other there's only you had to get one
and when you got one then they'd say
have you spoken to so-and-so and i'd say
like no i'd love to they're still alive
you know and they'd say yes they're
still alive we can we can i'll call them
right now.
so it was like putting together a sort
of mosaic do you speak russian quite
badly but good enough to um good enough
to get
to get to know these people
where did you find her
martha petsco basically where is she she
is still living on gorky's her
grandfather's estate
which is just outside moscow gorky the
most famous writer of the stalin period
and um so she was like a child of
complete privilege and she was the
ultimate soviet princess i mean she and
stalin's daughter it was not for nothing
they were best friends they were the two
they were the children of the two most
they were the families of the two most
famous people in the soviet union
and you talked to svetlana or did you
talk to somebody
but you told a very interesting story in
here about where she is today and where
she lived
trace that well she's been all over the
place you know she's had a she's she's
had a very turbulent life i think she's
in wisconsin i believe um and i did try
i approached her but i think she's just
tired of being stalin's daughter like
which is understandable
she left the soviet union twice she
married an american at one point called
peters
she returned to russia she returned to
she was in england she's been everywhere
and recently she's just moved to america
she's had a terrible life and you know
being stalin's family has been a sort of
curse that's partly what this this
book's a story of it's it's of the
families you know the women the wives
especially
and um but also it's about what it was
like to be a child you know there were
about 20 people in this inner circle and
they'd known each other for 30 years and
they rose to power and they killed
millions of people
and then they killed started killing
each other
and um and that that's the story so it
was a very peculiar and extraordinary
and unique time in history that these
people grew up and that's why to this
day they're linked together and why one
had to immerse oneself in this to try
and imagine how it felt
to be there and um
and i think that you know the materials
that i had both interviews and these new
archives and the visits to the houses
and so on
really i mean one had to have all three
to really put this together and create
this this new picture of of of what it
was like in the in in stalin's court
because we were talking about barrier go
to the end at stalin's
last couple of days and set that up and
by the way before you do that how long
did he live stalin 74 years from when to
win 1878
to 1953 5th of march 1953 he died and
how much how many of those years was he
in power well he was really empowered
much earlier than anyone realizing lenin
died in 1924 but one of the interesting
things is when you look at this he was
really running the soviet union from
1923 as the first of a small group of
people
from 1929 he was the leader
um
and um and from 1937 he was the leader
with absolute power of life and death
over everybody so it was a sort of it
grew it was very slow he was very
cautious extremely clever politicians
subtle and he meandered his way to where
he wanted to get to and that's one of
the things that are different in this
book by the way about the normally it's
just presented he's just he just bursts
on the scene until after levin's death
as this kind of dreaded satanic
omniscient sort of demigod um
seething with evil evil and an absolute
power not true know one of the things
this shows is that
until 1937 when he suddenly unleashed
this great terror he wasn't a figure of
fear to people at all in fact they were
so intimate with him they were hap they
were happy you know they felt very
comfortable with him and indeed you know
one of the fascinating things i found
was in 1935 when most books say the
terror had already begun and everyone
was quivering with fear he invited the
sphenidsis who were a couple who were
very close to him i'm always fat they
were family he invited them to dinner
they forgot to turn up they forgot to
turn up to dinner with stalin you know
which gives you an idea they were so
comfortable with him they remembered two
hours late and they turned up and stalin
was grumpily um playing billiards with
his bodyguards well these people were
shot two years later
or arrested two years later and later
shot not for missing dinner but because
they interfered with stalin's feeling of
separateness his messianic
mission he felt very special it wasn't
for nothing that we know we discovered
that he loved watching john ford
american movies directed by john ford
often with john wayne in them um he
loved that because that's exactly how he
saw himself it turns out as a sort of
the lone cowboy always alone no family
an
invented name no friends just the
mission riding alone into town
gunslinging you know ready to shoot out
anything that was him a marxist cowboy
and that's in a way how he saw himself
and why he spent his last eight years
just watching cowboy film after cowboy
film night after night running the
soviet union from his private cinema
that's one that's the sort of that's
very much the picture after the war
so at the end
where is he he's at his house at
conservo principal
is what his dacha just outside moscow i
mean one of the things one discovers in
this in this story is that stan didn't
really live in the kremlin i mean
russians thought he lived in the kremlin
and everyone else thought he lived but
in fact he lived at these country houses
and his main residence in around moscow
was conservo this um two-story rather
ugly mansion which he built for himself
after his wife's death moved in there
and that's where he lived he used to
shut himself in at night
guards were in guard houses right about
inside this house he had two dining
rooms
various bedrooms and a library his
beloved library and a cottage next to it
have you been there no i haven't been
this closed and in fact no connections i
could pull would get me there but what
is marvellous is that i've he has he had
exactly the same house built in the
south 15 of these different houses some
of them are imperial palaces converted
some of them are special stalin houses
built for him and i've been to all of
them and um and in fact there's a story
there which which i which which is kind
of interesting and talks about how
relevant stalin is today i went down to
these 15 houses
um which are fascinating i photographed
them in the book and no one's ever been
there when i was going around them um i
had to fly
by un helicopter into this bandit um
torn republic called abkhazia on the
black sea which is beautiful but but but
in a terrible situation i went around
all the houses extraordinary buildings
all of them and as i went around i said
to one of the old ladies who were caring
for me i said by the way has anyone you
know been here a bit worried that you
know taubman or anne applebaum or
richard pipes would have been there the
day before he said no no no one's been
here for years they said um in fact
you're the only person to see all of
them except in the 1970s we had an arab
visitor an arab gentleman who came and
he insisted on seeing every single house
that starred in a lived-in and i said
who was that and they said saddam
hussein and of course saddam was
obsessed with stalin and um based
himself on stalin and in fact they were
they were born about 500 miles apart if
you look at the map tikrit
gory very close
and um interesting i've spoken to some
people recently who've um who've been
talking to
talking to people who were close to
saddam
and apparently he was he read every
single book on stalin converted into
arabic and more than that he on his last
you know years he was constantly saying
i studied stalin because there's a man
who was in power for 30 years
and died peacefully in his bed
neither of which stalin's amsterdam is
going to achieve i think but uh we may
never get to the death scene but i want
to that's right no i want to ask you
though about the u.n helicopter how'd
you get to you into flying in um well i
i you had to sort of you had to um i had
to sort of um negotiate with them for
ages because why would they even take
you in at all i don't know i managed to
get them tight that's one of the things
you have these books are like detective
stories you know you have to i i the
reason the answer is i got the british
ambassador to ask them to take me in
um the english ambassador to georgia
which is now an independent country but
you know this book was such an adventure
i mean everything about it was an
adventure you know whether an
intellectual adventure or a physical
event this was part of the physical
adventure um
and um
it was quite scary because the un
helicopters have been shot down recently
by sort of no one knows who by just shot
out of the sky they're russian
helicopters so they're terrifying to
travel in in the first place there's
always sort of fuel leaking out of
somewhere you know but i had to get to
these houses and in fact it was very
important so much of what happened
especially after the war so much the
cold war the korean war stalin's part in
the korean war happened at these houses
in the south stalin was there for six
months of every year
after the war so you know it was very
very important that i got i got to see
these places did he go to all 15 all of
them all the time he moved around all
the time and in every room he slept in
every room and he had all sorts of
strange sort of details i discovered
like for example the baths were all tiny
because they were made exactly to fit
him and he was just he was sort of just
not much over five foot
tiny and um and so the baths actually
all of them were exactly his size when i
got into one of these baths and i might
i could hardly sort of i couldn't lie
down in it you know it was tiny um by
the way you say in your book he was five
six five six yeah five six years just a
bit over five foot that's right
and so um the u.n flew you to each one
of them no they flew me in and then they
said we can't guarantee your safety in
this place but you're on your own now
and i met up with the sort of abkhazian
professor who's called slava lacoba who
knew this story these places inside out
he's the sort of expert there locally
he took me around to all these houses
and they are some of them are very
beautiful houses it's normally written
that they're very grim
ugly
um you know sort of but in fact they're
rather beautiful but the fascinating
about all of them is that they're all
invisible i mean wherever you are
looking up at them you can't see them
and yet from that's that he obviously
chose them as eeries you know like
hitler he loved being in the sky you
know
and they're really beautiful i mean they
often have sort of summer houses built
on the edge of a cliff overhanging the
sea
they always um had their own paths and
little pagodas and often stalin would
walk down
these little paths and have a picnic
outside i mean the styling of georgia
was different
from the grim character we think of in
in in in moscow
so the death bed the
quiet death scene well you've got to
picture this scene it's extraordinary
since darling is now getting older he's
getting forgetful but he's still he's 74
years old he is still the great
manager of of camp of struggle of terror
um he's still running this campaign
against the it's basically an
anti-american campaign against the jews
against his own doctors against his own
colleagues and he's he's running this
sort of anti-zionist doctor's plot
and um
and he's suffering from arterial
sclerosis and when his doctors tell him
they say you've got to stop working so
much you're suffering from severe
arterial sclerosis
he had them arrested he saw that as an
attempted sort of coup against himself
quite rightly because if he had to work
leslie were they taking power away from
him so he was um but he was actually in
a very good mood he loved running
running a purge running a terror
campaign
um you know he was never happier when he
was when he was administering a new sort
of terrorist intrigue and at the height
of this he has dinner with his usual
four companions khrushchev uh
and himself and they have their dinner
they get drunk they talk about these
they'll talk about the interrogation of
the doctors um this is in march of seven
uh this is the 28th of february 28th of
february 1953
and they're at the dachshund they're
drinking wine and they drink till four
in the morning or whatever eisenhower
has just become president eisenhower has
just become president um and um the
height of the cold war the korean wars
going on um american troops are there
chinese troops are there let me ask you
though but bulgan was white at that
point bulgarnin was top politburo member
um and ran them at defence ministry uh
at various times jeff khrushchev was
a senior party official running moscow
malenkov was stalin sort of deputy in
the party
barrier was not head of the secret
police at this point barry was head of
the nuclear project and ran a huge part
of the economy he was deputy prime
minister stalin was prime minister and
head of the party secretary general of
the party you say in your book that
stalin and barry had despised each other
they did i mean did they know i mean did
either did they know about the other
despising them yeah i think they did i
mean um stalin was kind of started the
trouble is that stalin was simon was
ultimately a practical politician and he
knew that there were plenty of useless
people around but barrier was the most
was the most efficient was his most
brilliant sidekick so he didn't want to
get rid of him but he wanted to make
sure that he he stayed you know
submissive but yeah they hated each
other barry had once loved stalin but he
came to despise him and stalin regarded
him as a sort of vulgar policeman we
have a picture of uh stalin marching in
his white outfit that's a great picture
isn't it now what that picture is um
soon after the war now that is stalin's
generalissimos uniform which was
specially designed for him he feared
that he looked like a band leader in it
and um and he sort of some tall officers
were brought into his office to model it
for him and he kept hitting it but in
the end he wore it now in that picture
far left is
while i left it because mikoyan is on
the far left dapper armenian very clever
very wily the man who survived until
brezhnev's time the great survivor of
soviet union we saw anastasia
forever in our lives he came to jfk's
funeral he was he was chris jobs
representative of jfk's funeral so he
was he's part of american history too so
if he was a jfk streamr he was also at
lennon's funeral he carried that's right
he's an amazing character he carried
lennon's coffin and he attended jack
kennedy's funeral that gives you an idea
of his span his political span a giant
of the 20th century to his left our
right who is that chris chof nikita
khrushchev uh toothy ball juggy bumpkin
um cunning
tireless and a stalinist fanatic into uh
stalin's right malenkov flabby nicknamed
hipped
no no didn't need to shave um horrible
sinister character i'm known by all by
the uh by the feminine nickname melanie
for his feminine femininities high voice
and who is the gentleman next to him uh
barrier very unusually dressed as a
martial of the soviet union
um and we've talked about barrier
pervert predator
sadist brilliant manager on his left our
right um uh
molotov the um
foreign minister he actually you know
foreign minister very famous urbain
diplomat
very cold ruthless the robespierre of
the um of the uh soviet leadership okay
back to february 2018. we're at dinner
we're drinking
the the other four leave when you say
drinking that that is that's a theme
throughout this whole drinking gets
worse and worse and worse how much do
they what do they drink well they drink
they drink a lot of vodka a lot of
brandy and they drink a lot of georgian
wine and they also love champanski you
know crimean champagne which darling
adored but stalin himself by this time
was drinking very little he drank what
he called a juice which was sort of
georgian wine with water in it and the
others were expected to drink heavily
and they were often sick at the you know
these these were sort of vomit flecked
routes you know they would they would
often be made to drink and drink and
drink and they would often vomit at the
table or just stagger out
how do you know that we know from all
the memoirs of the different people
we've um you know there's no doubt about
it there's absolutely strong evidence
for this they would dance together um
the men were dancing because there were
no women at these dinners by the end i
mean these were extraordinary scenes
these were baccanals slow dancing they
were slow dancing between men and in
fact you know they would often use that
to sort of whisper to it molotov would
like slow dance with one of the polish
communist leaders and then he'd whisper
and whisper in his ear
you've got enemies in your army find
them and then stalin would the polish
guy would look up and stalin would be
would be nodding because he'd he'd have
organized this little moment you know
so these dinners were extraordinary you
know
stalin's daughter svetlana would
sometimes come down and she said it was
like the boyars of peter the great it
was such a it was so appalling stalin's
secretary posher would would be would be
dragged out um he was the head he was
always made to drink the most he was
made to sort of bumper whole glasses of
champagne while we're on that name
we may or may not get to the death
while we're on that name say it again
because it was the hardest name
who who was he he was a key person who
no one really has but he was he was an
extremely ugly little man um once a
medical orderly who was starring chef de
cabinet i mean his chief of staff his
chief of staff i mean he was really the
chief of staff when the chief of staff
of the white house is a is a huge
well-known public official but in their
world the chef de cabinet the chief of
staff was this kind of secret person and
he really ran stalin's complete
political world for him and did
everything who was in his family um uh
well he had he had a very pretty wife
what was her name who was called bronca
and she was like jewish like many of the
women around these people she was jewish
flirtatious sort of semi-polish it was
lithuanian which was you know sort of
polish lithuanian from a good family and
she had married into this terrible group
of people and um
and she was like she was great fun
stalin liked her she was flirtatious
with stalin um
and um but she was distantly related to
trotsky fatal fatal thing to be very
distantly like something like her
sister's husband was
um his sister was married to the the son
of
trotsky chotsky's son so it was very
diffused why is that bad
stalin was obsessed with trotsky trotsky
was his great villain the great enemy
and um
stalin had made his career by basically
destroying trotsky who killed trotsky um
stalin ordered it he tried to kill him
teen times and finally he called him
barrier and sudden platof who was this
sort of master of special tasks in the
secret place and he said just destroy
him i want him i want him done executed
in 1940.
they found them they knew where he was
of course and they infiltrated someone
into his circle
and then they killed him with an ice axe
and stalin was thrilled with that he
gave medals to all the people involved
in mexico in mexico city uh
i i really can't pronounce that name is
pus
off
yeah uh what happened to his wife um
well she made a mistake her brother was
also arrested and he was he was a
kremlin doctor top top crime and doctor
and so she went to stalin to ask
for um for for his release
and um and some people say that they had
an affair that which i think is very
unlike unlikely probably but she then
went to bury her to ask for the release
and barry arrested her
and of course her husband was just
desperate to um to get her released and
went to star and went to bury and begged
them to release him and stalin said i'm
sorry but i'm sorry sasha that's what he
called him he said i'm sorry sasha but
you know if you really miss her we'll
find you another wife
typical stalin sort of horrible dry joke
gallows humor and she was kept in prison
and gradually
you know the his chief of staff realized
that that um he wasn't his wife was
never going to come back
and um and she was kept in prison she
was interrogated as a trotskyite and as
a pole and as a jew and she had a lot of
things working against her and as
someone who'd asked stalin to release
her brother started hated women coming
to him and asking these embarrassing
questions he presented it enormously and
um and postgraduate continued to work as
stalin's loyal um dog-eared um chief
staff did not like him
he loved him he worshipped him even
though he took his wife away from he
thought that was business as usual and
one of the key things in this book to
understand is that these weren't like
normal people they weren't like normal
politicians they talked about themselves
these bolsheviks as knights in shining
armor who would chop off what is rotten
they regarded themselves as a sort of
order armed order of warrior priests and
they believed fanatically in marxism
leninism which meant the random
destruction of classes of people now
in order to create the perfect workers
paradise later did he ever get his wife
back no she was um she was kept in
prison and justice stalin in the in the
second world war begun when after hitler
had invaded in 1941
um uh stardon had a shot
um and of course postgraduate knew
nothing about this and never quite knew
what had happened to her but he knew
that she'd crossed that terrible line
because in these group of people you
were a leader you called all the other
leaders comrade or by their first names
when you were arrested and you were
named as an enemy of the people you just
disappeared you crossed the line from
being a sort of
one of these citizens one of these
leaders
well an aristocrat really
and all a member of this order of armed
of armed maniacs as it were you crossed
that line and you became nothing like
dust and in fact they often used to say
barry are you who behaved like a film
noir villain all the time used to say to
people i'll grind you i'll grind you
into camp dust which is just typical of
this sort of horrible people okay
february 28th and we've got to get
they're drinking and they're drinking a
lot and they're drinking a lot and they
they're talking about the doctor's
confessions stalin's saying have you
managed to beat her we've got to beat a
confession out of these doctors have
they admitted yet being agents of the
american zionist conspiracy and they
were talking about that and they talked
about the korean war apparently about
how it was time to maybe it was time to
make peace but stalin said no it's
better if we just keep bleeding the west
and just keep it going longer
and
they split in the early hours
and by about six o'clock the next night
you know a whole day had gone past
everyone was waiting to hear from stalin
but no one had heard from him
and um
and sometime at that
sometime during that day stalin suffered
a stroke he was in his pajamas and he
was holding the newspaper and a bottle
of a bottle of mineral water and he was
wandering around in his private
apartments
and he he fell down
he was soaked in his own urine
and he was lying there and he couldn't
move he was awake and he he was waiting
to be discovered
everyone was the bodyguards were getting
very nervous because they never went in
you see until they were called
and
they waited and waited wait and finally
they went in and they saw him they crept
in
the post arrived so they had an excuse
to go in
and then they found him there lying in
this vision they were terrified they
they immediately rang up barrier and
malenkov and all these characters
and they were all terrified too because
the doctors had just been arrested for
saying he was ill so they had to be they
had to make damn sure he really was ill
before they did anything and that's why
stalin was sort of left for 12 hours
effectively lying in his own urine
waiting to be got up getting colder and
colder i mean his staff lifted him up
and put him on a sofa
and then after a while by the way you
have a picture in the book of the sofa i
do yeah i have a picture of this and you
say he had those everywhere he had them
everywhere i've seen many of them and
they're all the same they're all huge
you can actually sleep on them and he
moved around and he said he he said he
said i always move her he told visitors
he used to say i don't sleep in the beds
here he said i sleep in the sofas and i
move around every night i sleep in a
different one he always went to sleep
reading you know he was an obsessional
reader he just lied there he was an
insomniac he told churchill he said i'd
never get to sleep till four at least
that's why he had these dinners and then
he just he just read a history book or
literature or something and then he just
um he'd finally fall asleep wherever he
happened to be and that was the way he
liked it it was a habit he'd got you
know these people were formed by their
life as underground itinerant
revolutionaries and stalin never really
lost the habits of this itinerary being
an itinerant revolution he loved that he
loved that life really he was born for
it and so even when he was leader of the
greatest empire in the world he still
lived in that way though of course on a
vast scale with 15 or 20 houses kept
staffed at all times
but anyway to get back to the death
um uh anyway so there you have him he's
lying on the floor he's lying on he's
lying on the floor sort of begging to be
got up he can't speak he's had his
stroke he's had a huge stroke a fatal
stroke and by the way you say that he
had a pulse of 78
and his blood pressure was 190 over 110.
yeah and normal is what 120 over seven
yeah i'm not sure what stage that that
that is but whenever it was when he was
first med exam medically i guess it was
early yeah but this this when we're
talking he still hasn't even been he
still hasn't been really sort of no one
no doctors have seen him yet they're
just waiting to see they think he might
just have a hangover and they're waiting
to see if he's going to wake up and
meanwhile none of them dare go in they
come and they go and barrier meets
christoph and chris they can't find
barrier at first but he's clearly with
some woman he's got this this time by
the way he had a 14 year old mistress a
gorgeous 14 year old
yeah a 14 year old mistress who's who is
absolutely
absolutely beautiful girl and how old
would he have been oh well he was 53 54
and um
and she was kept in all the finest
houses and she had her own driver and
you know this was sort of
you know this was really it wasn't a
very communist life they were leading by
this point you know this is this is
really about privilege about a ruling
class but anyway they finally found
barrier and he said just leave it be
careful
um you know don't go in there and
finally they they waited till the staff
were desperate the staff kept ringing
we've got to have a doctor you know we
think he really is ill so finally the
leaders drove up outside
and they saw the four and they had this
frantic negotiations about what
who would go in and in the end they
crept in barrier and malenkov the
dominant people really the sort of the
two leading officials crept in
and barrier was typical barrier sort of
arrogant and um
and and uh haughty malenkov who was sort
of melanie melenkov as he was nicknamed
by the other leaders and took his shoes
off typically and carried them you know
he was walking along in his socks he was
terrified of terrified of um starting
waking up and asking what he was doing
there and they looked in and finally
they began to figure out that maybe he
was ill but they decided let's wait till
morning so we'll see what's happened so
now we're really talking it's many hours
since stalin's had the stroke and in the
morning it's clear that he really is ill
they call the doctors
the leaders turn up and then they begin
fighting for the um for the for the
succession and they begin to make deals
then you've got stalin's son vasily
drunk drunk useless son coming in
shouting at them all you bastards have
killed my father you've got khrushchev
and barrier bargaining in the back you
know
in the back room they're always doctor
young doctors hanging around
the the specialist doctors are too
frightened to touch him and in fact when
they started to examine him their hands
were shaking so much that they couldn't
get his shirt off
he was wearing a shirt now they put on a
um they put a dressing gown and he was
cold when they found him you see and so
they they said um go on to examine him
and this um this specialist this
professor started sort of trying to and
he just he had these scissors he was
going to try and cut the shirt off and
he just dropped it so barry said to him
pull yourself together examine him
properly he's you're patient
so it was kind of by the way how old was
vecille his son then oh his facility was
1921. so he was 30 you know he was in
his 30s um 21 the 50s you know he was he
was yeah he was he was sister and he was
in his 30s and and the um
and then they tried to get his full
teeth out we have a picture of it there
he is there he is the crown prince as he
was known by by all the inner circle by
the way hold this false teeth story
because while you're on him just for a
moment yeah what was the mayday story
when he was
fired because of uh the bombers he was
grossly over promoted um he really was
ridiculously spoiled half terrified half
complete a complete bully typical
mixture dictator's son he was a sort of
uday the uday saddam hussein of the
regime if you like
and he was drunk he was a general of the
air force and he had he was always
flying drunk and typically during a very
um bad weather he gave orders that these
bombers could fly over the fly pass on
red square which we've all seen on the
news
where the leaders from from lenin's
mausoleum viewed these fly passes and
parades and two of the planes crashed
one of the planes crashed and um and
stalin was furious and sacked him and
then it then started had to face up to
the fact that vessel was it was a
completely chronic alcoholic and then
stalin put insisted on putting him slime
was very concerned
and he put him into the sort of soviet
version of the betty ford clinic which
was you know obviously this whole group
of people were such a collection of sort
of murderers drunks
sadists i mean you know that um they
were just they were just a group of sort
of degenerates essentially and vasily
stalin was the classic
and you know it wasn't for nothing they
called him the crown prince let me read
from the death chapter uh once he was it
was proved that he was incapacitated
yeah barrier quote spewed forth his
hatred of stalin unquote but whenever
his eyelids flickered or his eyes opened
bury it terrified that he would recover
quote knelt and kissed his hand
like an oriental
was it fisher vizier yeah
uh at uh sultan's bedside that's right
that's right i mean but you have a
couple of occasions in here where yeah
when his eyelids were closing he was out
he started screaming to him yeah i mean
he'd say you know he was basically sort
of saying die you revolting old man when
stalin was when stalin was unconscious
and when his eyelids flickered he'd
throw himself on the floor kiss his hand
say comrade's starting we long for you
to return will you will you come back
and you know will you lead us i mean
barrier
is a film noir character of course this
was barry's undoing he wasn't he wasn't
sensible he couldn't help showing off he
thought he was cleverer than everybody
else
he frightened everybody else and that
was that doomed him in the end well you
also say here perhaps 20 million had
been killed 28 million deported of whom
18 million had slaved in the gulags yet
after so much slaughter they were still
believers
did you have a total figure of how many
humans stalin was responsible for
killing murdering or starving you know
we'll never know
um what's your best guess i think
something like 30 million i think
something like 30 million but that that
line is the most one of the most
important in the book you know after
after say 30 million had died after 30
million have been through camps and
deportation you know so we're talking 60
million victims of this
of this this monstrous regime these
these absolute diabolical characters
they still believed they believed until
they died they were absolute fanatics
that's that's the key they were
religious fanatics and they had much
more in common with the taliban or the
ayatollahs or osama bin laden in a way
than they did with a secular party they
talked all the time about this as they
said they talked when stalin was killing
people i found notes in these amazing
archives which i found which i was using
which in which he said you know we've
got to kill these people we've got to
finish them off because they've lost
faith which is interesting interesting
choice of words so the teeth the false
teeth
we're back at the bedside now and they
they've just managed to shakely take off
style and shirt but they're so
frightened and then when it's time to
take out their teeth they're so
frightened they drop the teeth they take
out stalin's pulse if they drop them on
the floor they go stalin's dentures go
clattering across the um across the
floor of um the dacha and um and then
they begin to you know then they finally
stalin lies there and they begin the
doctors begin to examine him and they
find out that he is incapacitated as you
said and that um
and that stalin is never going to come
back
and then they begin this sort of
wheeling they actually keep him alive
longer rather like they did with matt
chem and mao and with brezhnev in fact
they sort of and with marshall tito it's
a sort of there's a sort of feature of
these sort of regimes they keep them
alive especially longer in order to
check that everything's settled the
collective leadership isn't in place and
of course they bargain to let each other
each other off to blame for various
atrocities as well deals are being made
and the old man's breathing they're
surrounded by his daughter the drunk son
vasily
and um and all the leadership
fascinating moment when's he die he dies
in the evening of the fifth of march
1953
and a barrier has managed to secure for
himself the dominant position of control
of all the security services the whole
gulag empire as well as being
a keeper and deputy prime minister barry
darted forward and ritually kissed the
warm body first the equivalent of a
wrenching a dead king's ring off his
finger
yeah where did you find that
um well i i've i said that it was the
equivalent of um taking the you know how
they used to rip the the where'd you
find the story of the details on that
they're various they're all sorts of
accounts i mean mikoyan left an account
kaganovich left an account that lana
left an account we have quite a lot of
accounts of these scenes now molotov
cried mourning stalin despite his own
imminent liquidation and that of his
wife that's right how were they
liquidated um they weren't liquidating
they were about to be liquidated molotov
was stalin's oldest
comrade his um the second man of the
regime in the public eye anyway stalin
had turned against him
and
sta molotov's wife was polina was a
jewess
and she had met golda mayo when golden
mayor visited
moscow in 1948 and she'd re-established
she was a bolshevik a tough woman a hard
bolshevik woman who believed in all this
killing who believed in the whole regime
the whole of stalin's polina paulina and
by the way golomeyer used to run israel
was that she was prime minister of
israel milwaukee wisconsin that's right
okay golda meirson from mil from
milwaukee
um
so but she you know she but she'd she'd
always start annoyed stalin part of the
reason for the reason was that she was
jewish part of the reason that she was
very independent part of the reason was
that she was a sort of feminist and
therefore had risen to being a minister
in the government in her own right but
part of it was that she'd been best
friends with stalin's wife the late
nadia who committed suicide
and stalin never really forgave
paulina for being that close
to um to to nadia and so he'd always
sort of plan to destroy her and he'd
almost destroyed her in 1939. in fact at
one point he said should we should we
kill her he said to barry should we kill
her in a um faked car crash anyway but
they decided not to and she survived
another 10 years and then in 1948 49 she
was arrested and she was accused of
having sexual relations with hundreds of
young men in sort of politburo gangbangs
if you like which is just completely
unbelievable sort of accusation she was
accused of having group sex
um and she was a you know a respectable
grandmother a matron by this point it
was completely ludicrous and start
molotov was sitting at the table when
stalin read out these accusations and he
said my knees were knocking i realized
that this was very serious so what
happened to the two of them well nothing
happened to um molotov except that he
had to vote for her
leaving the party he had to divorce her
and um she was then arrested
and um and she was put taken taken away
sent to exile and he did not see her for
three more three or four more years and
he believed she was probably dead she
wasn't in fact she was kept secretly and
he continued to be a member of the
pollock bureau he said he was stacked as
foreign minister but he remembered that
he continued to be deputy premier to
work um all the time um he ceased to be
stalin's most trusted person in fact
stalin hardly saw him anymore and saw
him less and less stalin despised him by
then
because we've we i don't have much time
i want to
get to bury it for a moment
he became the leader he became the first
man of the collective
eclectic regime the power he became the
sort of power man how long just for 100
days three months who eliminated him
christoph who killed him um a marshal
the general was brought in to kill him
and um
and
he was arrested in a sort of coup
and um after the hundred days after the
hundred days christoph arranged it
everyone else signed off on it they
arrested him they kept him in secret for
some months then they tried him he wrote
letters to them all saying please
release me and then they they took him
out and they sentenced him to death
and he started shouting and saying you
can't kill me i'm burying this they
stuffed the towel in his mouth and then
they couldn't find anyone everyone was
too frightened to shoot him so they had
to get a very senior officer to kill him
they got a general obscure general
they've got him out he came out and he
just shot him right in the forehead
and
then he was cremated
and and his ashes were thrown into one
of those graveyards in moscow when so
many of his victims ashes had also been
thrown where is stalin today he is he is
um apparently quite well preserved but
against the kremlin wall buried under
the kremlin wall and there's a statue in
there behind len's mausoleum but no one
no no tour guide will point it out to
you
and london's still in this tomb that
incident is to
yeah when you say the kremlin uh you've
been there yeah did you go through i
mean explain what the kremlin is well
the crown is fascinating it isn't it
isn't like the white house it's not one
building it's 69 acres a sort of um
almost like a sort of medieval russian
disney world of history i mean it's got
you know you've got ivan the terrible
buried there you've got churches
courtyards palaces and of course all
these people the whole leadership lived
in these in about two buildings in
inside the kremlin and saw each other
every day their families were next to
each other um they often had doors into
each other's apartments um the stalins
the the mikoyans the molotovs the
berries all lived close to not the
barriers in fact but they all lived very
close together and one of the
fascinating things in the notes
that i discovered the books based on the
archives which the book is really based
on stalin's own papers love letters
photo albums etc is that they would
constantly pop into each other's
apartments it was very informal power
was personal there and you'd often find
little notes that say hey molotov i
dropped into your apartment you weren't
there i'll come back later stalin you
didn't find those you found them there
these these these documents yeah i've
actually held these documents and worked
on them let me ask you because uh i want
to get your own story and where are you
from originally i'm from england where
from london where'd you go to school i
went to high school at harrah's school
which was um which was where winston
churchill went to school and quite a lot
of prime ministers and then i studied
history at cambridge university
um and then i did very i became an
investment banker for a while
and my family is a banking family
originally so i thought i might follow
follow that um follow that sort of
tradition but i
in 1991 the soviet union started to
break up and then i realized my destiny
was to see this history being made so i
went out there and became a sort of um
self-employed war correspondent had you
spoken russian before that no i didn't
speak a word of russian there not a word
i went out that i was in chechnya i was
in georgia i was in i was sitting on a
tank when they when boris yeltsin was
attacking his own white house in that
famous scene in 1993 you probably
remember i mean it was a life of
tremendous adventure and you're what 39
hours i'm 38 now so i was then
26 or seven or something and it was a
tremendous thing you know i was just
living this amazing life as a sort of
retired banker traveling to these places
and of course everywhere i went civil
war broke out i got to know the
president the warlord the you know the
i was traveling in these amazing convoys
of black mercedes with guys with guns
hanging off the um you know the walking
the the boards on the edge of them it
was just a great adventure and but i
also had some very frightening things
happen to me that made me realize i
didn't really want to be shot at that by
people who didn't even care who i was
and grossly was the last straw it was
very frightening so
then um so then after that i i love the
caucasus and that got me interested in
history i was a columnist for the sunday
times in london and the spectator and i
wrote a lot of the new republic here
um mainly on russia
and then i started to write history
books i became a historian full-time
historian and um
my first history book was about prince
potemkin catherine the great's lover and
that was based on correspondence that no
one had really seen before as well
and that's one that's a great story
that's the great sort of one of the
great
love stories of all of history catherine
and potemkin forget forget anthony and
cleopatra napoleon and josephine these
were amazing people did
did you have a
an interpreter when you would interview
people like uh martha peshkova yeah i
used an interpreter then my rations not
would not be good enough to um i
wouldn't run a risk missing stuff did
you tape those interviews yeah we take
those interviews how many did you do you
think
50 i should think total of all the old
yeah i mean how many of those folks are
still stalling this a lot of them are i
mean some of them are just terrifying i
mean andreas was one of andreas and dora
khazan
with a man and woman who stalin's two
closest and most vile um
collaborators their daughter and natasha
andrei ever i interviewed her she turned
out to be a terrifying character she
lent over towards me and she said you
know
she said my mother could tell an enemy
of the people just by looking into his
eyes
and my mother told me she said that i
had inherited that gift and then she
went right over to me and she pointed at
me and she said simon are you an enemy
of the people are you afraid of the red
flag
and i was pretty i was pretty afraid of
that moment as you can imagine but
interestingly she also said and by the
way she said my father never killed half
the people that you know that you say he
killed and you know and stalin killed
it's not true and that day funnily
enough i worked in the archives i wanted
to believe her but that day i went to
the archives i found andreas her
father's file
and it was a catalogue of absolute
mass murder on this it was a sort of
magical mystery tour of murder around
the whole soviet union there would be
telegrams that said to stalin from
andreas i've arrived in rostov i've been
rest i've arrested the entire
agricultural agricultural college five
ministers six party leaders seven
soldiers 25 of this 26 of that two tv
presenters and news readers or whatever
and he said i asked they're all enemies
of the people can i execute all of them
stalin would just write back praville
now right go right ahead and um
these are all these are all actually on
bit of bits of paper you can read in
addition to all this you and your wife
are somewhat known in great britain and
england as
i don't know what how to describe it
they you're friends of the royals
we know that we we are friends of the
royals friends of prince charles we are
friends of prince charles how did that
all come how long have you been married
uh we've been married about five years
and um
my wife's um mother
is is the prince of well one of the
prince of wales is best friends i think
it's probably true to say and um
so
when we got you know when we got married
and you know the prince of wales and
mrs parker bowles came to our wedding
and all this kind of this stuff so it's
kind of interesting we've
we've um
we love them and we we
i adore the prince of wales and i think
he's a he's a wonderful person great
friend does that ever help in in getting
access to some of this stuff you talk
about the british ambassador to russia
helping you open up uh you know the
flights in the u.n is that does that
spill over
no not really i i never i i wouldn't
sort of i keep i generally don't sort of
talk to help to involve it with my work
really i mean i think it's best to keep
these things separate where did you meet
your wife um
uh i met her i met her she was actually
working in a shop at one point grims
santa santa south american name
um yeah i met her i met her in a shop
funny enough and i thought my god she's
beautiful i must find out who she is
and um and later i did
and um
the rest is history how many kids got
two kids how old uh one's three lilly
and one's a boy called sasha nice
russian name and your wife's a writer
she's a writer she writes um she writes
romantic um sagas
normally with a south american she
speaks very good spanish so she knows
south america very well so they normally
have a latin they always normally have
some gauchos in there where did you do
all this work i mean how do you all were
you both writers you work in the same
place bizarrely our sort of our flat our
living conditions have deteriorated
since we've had children before running
out of room so at one point we were
actually i was writing stalin and she
was writing her romantic
novels in one room and we we shared a
study the kids have run riot around the
rest of the house so
bizarrely we'd be writing these
completely opposite she'd be writing
these wonderful sweeping love stories
well i'd be just immersed in this in
this chronicle of just murder and
perversity
are you a fast writer
i'm pretty fast right how many words a
day
um
i don't know thousands i mean i'd play
music very loudly to get to get it
through often i'd play russian the red
army choir i listened to a lot when i
was writing this
shelby foote
says that he writes about 500 words a
day that's all well sometimes like
sometimes i don't get much done i mean
there's some really difficult i worked
really hard on this book i mean i really
when did you finish this book i finished
it
just over a year ago and i i mean what i
was trying to do it was just trying to
write a book that even if no one for
people who'd never read a read a book on
stalin you know
who might never read another book on
stalin this should be the star and book
that they read that's what i wanted to
do but i also wanted it to be completely
scholastically
um founded in um in the archives and i
hope that it succeeds in that
our guest has been simon seabag
montefiore this is the cover of the book
stalin the court of the red czar thank
you very much thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for a dvd or videotape call 1877
on cspan
for a free transcript or to learn more
about book notes visit us at
booknotes.org
next week on book notes part two of the
interview with simon seabag montefiore
author of stalin the court of the red
tsar
book notes can be seen every sunday on
c-span at 8 pm eastern and 8 p.m pacific
time
[Music]
on book tv tonight author bill salmon on
his book misunderestimated read a
transcript and review the book
[Music]
this week on book notes part two of a
two-part interview with author simon c
bag monty fiore he joins us to discuss
his book stalin the court of the red
czar
[Music]
simon sebag monteviori author of stalin
what was the great terror the great
terror was when
in a in a complete paroxysm of um of a
witch hunt really um stalin and his top
people decided to cull the whole
leadership of the communist party
and um and kill about a million of them
what year 1937
um the bizarre thing we we always knew
that stalin has really started the great
terror started in his top people
what we've only realized now is that how
exactly it was done and there are memos
in this in this treasure trove of
archives that i've used for this book
there's a memo
in which stalin molotov the others send
it out to the provinces and they say
basically
you've got to kill people at random
you've got to kill so for example they
sent out to different cities minneapolis
killed twenty thousand people dallas
killed thirty thousand people new york
fifteen thousand people la ten thousand
people just kill em kill the enemies for
what i mean how do they
decide who well this is the heart of
bolshevism this is what people often
don't realize it's often always like
stalin did everything stalin was the
great monster of this period true he was
the great monster but the bolshevik
mindset was the real was the real
culprit here um as well
what is a bolshevik absolutely the
bolshevik is the bolsheviks were the
that were that were their name for
themselves the it means the majority in
russian but in fact they were a tiny
group of people
less than 10 000 people and when they
seized power in 1917 they were so small
it was like lyndon larouche taking power
in america literally
a weird sect of extremists taking power
in in a giant empire where was stalin in
relation to ship to lenin in 1917.
pretty close
um uh lennon came
came back to um petersburg and arranged
the caesar of power stalin had been in
exile when azal abdicated he'd come back
to petersburg as well
lenin had two most trusted
troubleshooters trotsky and stalin
absolute opposites trotsky intellectual
haughty jewish a man of the european
intellectual
stalin
uh a cobbler's son from georgia rough
ruthless
highly intelligent sharp cunning they
hated each other starting had a huge
chip on his shoulder
trotsky had a sort of
uh in
superiority complex if you like where
was uh lennon from originally well he
was from he was a russian he was from um
he was
he was from the urals i think and he was
um
he was he was a descent of sort of a of
jewish and german and and russian
descents he was mixed descent
and um where was trotsky from um he was
from odessa
and
georgia would be how many people back in
those days oh it's tiny it was like now
it's like it's five million people so
it's tiny then it was like a million
people probably was the soviet when was
it when it was the soviet union put
together well ninety it remained
together after the you know the civil
war it didn't fall apart during the
civil war it was held together finally i
mean it fell apart for a while
um but was it together before 17 19 yeah
it was it was it was the czars had
finland they had poland
um and um and they had the baltic states
and they had um the caucasus so they had
this kind of vast empire and then when
the revolution happened it all fell
apart for a while and these different
things became independent they lost the
baltic states then in 1918 they lost the
caucasus but they got the caucasus back
it's very complicated but basically the
soviet union took over what it could of
the czarist empire when the soviet union
was together i remember they had about
286 million people
russia itself had about 150 million what
was it back in 1917 that whole
conglomeration of 15 countries i'm not
sure what the total population the
population was but it was it was it was
a powerful you know powerful empire then
and the bolsheviks never found um they
never found that a contradiction that
they would kept an empire together
they regarded that as as power behind
the hand as it were of marxism
and
just to go back to what bolsheviks are
they were this they were this powerful
armed order of a professional
revolutionaries fanatics to the
religious nth degree and in fact when
people said did stalin believe
um i think it was barry that said he was
a fanatic a quasi-islamic fanatic
interesting use of language considering
what we're facing now because this
really is the story i mean yes it's a
story of all the disgusting things this
is like the sort of 12 caesars um it's
like the twelfth season meets the
godfather um
you know it it's about depravity and
murder and sadism and privilege but it's
also about an ideal an ideal that was
rotten from the beginning you know
a lot of people said there was wonderful
lenin and then this this aberration
stalin ruined the revolution but the
idea was good
it wasn't good it was never good it was
based on murder from the beginning it
was always based on bloodletting what
year did lennon die 1924 january
and stalin was already very powerful by
that point
before he died lenin wrote wrote a
testament in which he tried to basically
destroy both his obvious successors
trotsky and and stalin and this is
pretty usual for dictators they never
want anyone to succeed them you know
without the world without them is
unimaginable
and of course he failed lenin to get rid
of either of these successors but stalin
was much the superior politician to
trotsky and using cunning and his
political machine
he was a superb political
um manager and personal manager
and trotsky was haughty had a sort of
messiah complex
and um and and was really very easy to
get rid of i mean this great idea of a
great struggle as it appears in history
books is nonsense stalin
destroyed these people very quickly and
very easily really you say that today
it's robert conquest versus the
revisionists yeah and robert conquest
has been here and we talked about the
great terror a great man of this subject
richard pipes why is he the great man of
this subject he said um he he understood
instinctively what this whole regime was
about
and
he said that stalin ordered the great
terror from the center
um and that um
and that you know it was it was stalin's
deviant personality and communism's
deviant nature that caused it he was
then attacked by a lot of people in
academia
who said it was the terror didn't really
happen it was all exaggerated
um you know the terror was a local thing
um less much less people were killed
so on and so forth
now you know in 2000 we suddenly have
these documents arrive which confirm him
to the nth degree but it also it
confirmed the revisionists in a strange
sort of way because
it showed from this member this kind of
random killing quote killing by quota
showed that conquest was right that it
was all done from the center by stalin
but actually when you look at it
you find out in these letters that i've
read you find out that these people were
killing their enemies locally too
a lot of people wanted the terror to
happen
a lot of the bolsheviks wanted to kill
their enemies the reason why it happened
really was because starting wanted to
destroy his old enemies he wanted to
make the communist party utterly
subservient and a lot of people agreed
with him because
the war was coming that's what it was
about the war was coming and you got to
realize in 1937 they were already at war
spanish civil was going on russia was
supporting the republic against the
fascists who were supported by hitler
and mussolini they were already
skirmishing with the japanese in the far
east in 1938 um hitler was rising
war was coming
so they were destroying the fifth column
or any sort of spies who might
um who might undermine them when the war
came that was the one of the ideas then
there was the enormous economic
efficiency how to explain it well they
were going to blame the corruption among
the top bolshevik people
and then
yeah
you referred to the memoranda and the
letters and all that where did you
find them in 2000 yeah i was just so
lucky what happened was
i realized that no one had written a
book
like this before no one had written an
intimate biography of stalin and the
reason why they had was because they
didn't have material but also because
oddly there was this kind of myth about
these communist leaders that they had no
private lives which is kind of
ridiculous
um
and um
and there's also sort of there's also
the feeling that their private lives
were not relevant to their political
lives this book is really about how the
private and the political and the public
were all the same i mean power was
private power was intimate the gossip
really mattered people died of gossip at
stalin's court and that's what this is
about
um but what happened was i arrived and
they said you know you know we could we
we've got all this all these archives
are opening now
and i went like what what is it and they
said it's stalin's papers we've just
opened half of the presidential archive
you know go right in we're in um the
ragaspi which is the communist party
archive in moscow
and there they had stalin's archives and
you know you could imagine my joy when i
found this material and no one else knew
that you were doing this well um yeah
other people knew about it i mean people
of yale have published
various collections from this arc but
it's millions of documents you see um
various american historians have sort of
begun to penetrate it but it was open
then so they could only begin then
really and you know it is such a wealth
of material did you worry that um that
there were people right over your
shoulder of course there were yeah
how did you keep track of them well i
you know
well i mean i just i just worked very
hard i mean i was so excited about what
i was finding but every day in there was
just a daily excitement you were just
newly married i was newly married then
yeah and my poor wife had to tolerate
stalin in our lives does she come to
moscow with you no she's never been to
russia actually which is funny because
it's my sort of hobby turned career but
um she's never been
by the way you keep hearing that these
archives wouldn't be available today
yeah is that true i think they're
closing a lot of them now i mean the
mystery of the archives opening closing
in russia is just another enigma another
another enigma of the east when the kgb
archive opened and closed i mean i'm
sure any of these archives will now
close it's just well it's just one of
the mysteries of russia just for a
moment take us through the process of
how you did this
you know how do you get the actual
papers out of the archive um it all
depends on the archivist
and um what you do is you you just ask
them for what they have now what the the
great thing this book is based on is
that
all the uh most of the american
academics were interested in the
politburo archives they were just going
through the official
um the official sort of decrees and
stuff but i noticed in the archive there
was this thing just said uh uh
miscellaneous correspondence a to z
so i i looked i thought that's
interesting and i began to look at it
and in that thing i found everything you
know i found a whole world huge boxes
they brought it in boxes and um and and
files
um and um
and they uh you know it's just
fascinating suddenly you in the world of
style and you could smell his pipe smoke
sometimes you could see tears on the
letters sent to him some of the letters
i mean the letters are such a variety
you know there are letters from groupies
to stalin for example which darling has
answered himself there's one letter that
says um
dear comrade stalin i'm a 23 year old um
school teacher you know female school
teacher from somewhere in the province
of siratov or somewhere um i'd love to
come and meet you on your own i had
fantasies and dreams about you many
chants i could come and see you you know
signed whatever and then it says ps
photographing closed you know
stalin's reply is there dear comrade
unfamiliar he writes um i i'm afraid i
don't have time to see you though i
respect your request yours joseph
started and then typical stalin's just
like um humor ps photograph returned you
know very stale and sort of dry but is
this a big place and there are a lot of
other people there yeah it's a hideous
it's a hideous concrete building so it's
1970s concrete building where you think
of lennon right near pushkin square
right in the center of moscow and it's
got this kind of place downstairs that
serves hideous borscht soup
um you know but you've got to eat in the
archive when you're in the arkham it's
part of the sort of experience
and um and you know i i got managed to
get a private room so i could look at
massive you know
i think if you did it properly
you had to you had to you could only
take out 10 files a day but i had a
private room and i was sitting there
with piles this high of documents now
did you have a translator with you on
the document sometimes but mainly not
because my russian i haven't i have
enough russian that i can read this
stuff with a dictionary i mean i learned
russian very late
when you learn things in your 30s you
suddenly find that your brain isn't as
good as it was when you were where did
you learn it i had a teacher and um i
had a tutor
and in russia or in great britain in
great britain
and how long did you study it um well i
started studying it to write my my first
book prince potemkin prince of prince's
um and it was really necessary then as
well because you know i was in ukraine
researching potemkin and no one speaks
english
in southern ukraine so i really needed
it um and you know you really do need
some russian just to sort of you're
going through these arguments you've got
to decide which is in what's interesting
and what isn't
and um unfortunately my russian is just
good enough to be able to do that now
did you make copies of what you got yeah
i wrote out everything i wrote
everything on little notes i'm very
old-fashioned i wrote the whole thing on
bits of note paper which i put in boxes
and filed in different places i've got
about 50 but you didn't make a a xerox
copy no i didn't not of all of them i've
got xeroxes of some of them
i translated them with myself or i got
help i mean oftentimes it was very hard
to understand stalin's writing
there's a lady in there called larissa
who is the great stalin
handwriting expert in the world so you'd
go and see her and you say this is
stalin isn't it she'd say yeah you say
what the hell does that say you know and
she'd say she'd tell you and she she was
very good natured and helped me a lot
and
um but you know the wealth of the
material is what we
struck one and that's what baseline i
mean as i said you know
there was there was an amazing intimacy
in this one there were love letters
molotov's love letters to his wife there
was stalin's love letters to his to his
wife and her love letters to him
which are very warm and normal and no
one else had used those no some people
have dipped into them i mean i'm not the
only person who's ever seen all this all
these materials but
i think about there probably a 500
documents in this book that are that no
one's ever used before but you rated uh
the archival material and your private
interviews in terms of what's the most
valuable and what is the most valuable
the archives and this sort of book has
to be based on archives because the
archives are real
and you know the interviews you know
you've got to be very careful i mean for
example um you know if you're going to
ask barry as you know daughter or
grandchildren or something you know um
or i mean sorry barry's your
daughter-in-law if you're going to ask
her a question she's not going to know
about politics there's no point in
asking what went on in the politburo but
you can ask her how often did stalin
visit their house
she'll know that you know so you just
got to sort of with with them with with
interviews you've got to very carefully
evaluate what um what use these people
are what can they know
i mean because they all they all think
they can talk about anything of course
but in fact as a historian you've got to
decide what they what what's worth
what's worth having from them by the way
did you write as you went or did you
write after you i wrote it all in one
one go when i had everything and how
long did that take you took me a full
year to write and rewrite and rewrite
okay i want to go back to some stories
and some names in here one name and that
i think this is connected with the great
terror is uh is it yeshof
yeah yes off yeah
y-e-z-h-o-v yeah who was he um
uh one of the great monsters of all
history fascinating character
how big was he he was a dwarf he was
literally a dwarf he was he was under
five foot or just five foot i think um
on the you know and he was um
he was dark good looking blue eyed had a
nice singing voice tiny
he was very coarse character he was
bisexual incredibly promiscuous left
with men and women throughout his career
a heavy drinker uneducated
peasant upbringing
and he was made stalin's absolute um top
man
by the way you say his hobby
uh his only hobby apart from partying
and fornicating
was collecting and making model yachts
yeah yeah now i gotta read that again
his hobby apart from partying and
fornicating was collecting and making
model yachts and killing people i mean
he was a frenzied torturer he was one of
the you know one of the fascinating
things about this is how close the
murdering and killing was to the cabinet
table you know in other words how close
these people the people were going from
their version of the oval office and
they actually were going straight to the
torture chambers and back you know
um it was a great scene for example in
the middle of the tarot yejoff is secret
police chief now
i found some fascinating correspondence
between stalin and the edge of which no
one had ever seen before and in one of
the things stalin says you know the
great thing about you yes is that if if
i give you something to do
it's always done
and stalin took immense trouble with
jesus and this is also one of the
lessons of this book is like starting
the people person the manager you know
stalin didn't sort of arrive as fully as
as a as the living god
like hitler he wasn't the fuhrer he had
to he had to win his he had to win his
way and charm his way to power and he
did that by taking care of people why
did he call him my blackberry oh because
because um because the word yes of
sounds very like the russian for
blackberry
you say he was russia's
um
greatest killer he was russia's greatest
killer he was a frenzied killer
um before he came to power as a secret
he was quite popular everyone thought he
was a very good bloke
but when he came to power he threw
himself into this with a frenzy now
stalin had taken great care of him as i
said he'd when he was ill stalin gave
enormous amounts of pocket money and
sent him to italy to um recuperate
and then when he came to power yes off
proved a frenzied killer who arrived at
the cabinet table with his cuffs
speckled with a brown subs brown red
substance and khrushchev who was there
said oh nicola ivanovic what have you
got on your cuffs
and um little the little
poison dwarf said i've been in working
the torture chambers all night i've just
come from there now this is the blood of
an enemy of the people
footnote
in one of the most sinister parts of the
research for this book the author
meaning you yeah stayed almost alone in
this strange but historic house
probably in
mandel stam's
attic yeah and that's all connected to
this story yeah well um uh one of the
hass islands i went to all of his houses
and in one of them in in sakumi which is
um which is uh
on the black sea um started had a
beautiful house which he often stayed in
in fact many of the party leaders stayed
in it it's actually a millionaires
mansion and it looks like one of those
kind of
um vanderbilt palaces you know it's a
great big white
um towered
um uh sort of palace really and um and i
went and stayed in that and anybody else
in there no one else was in there and it
was terrifying i mean when they heard i
was writing a book about stalin they
said well you could go and stay and it's
complete chaos in abkhazia you've got to
realize it's a sort of it's a
civil war it's a bandit republic he said
do you want to go and stay in stalin's
house i said like i suppose i must you
know be rude to turn that down so i went
and stayed in there and what happened in
this house apart from stalin stayed
there a lot was that the great poet
ossip mandelstam you know one of the few
good people in this book brave man
brilliant russia's great poet stayed
there with his wife when he was quite a
favored poet in the in about 1930 and at
exactly the same time
jejov was staying there as a young party
leader with his wife and he was trying
to seduce his the next weapon was a lot
of sort of there was a lot of sex going
on in this group there's a lot of
seduction a lot of debauchery especially
among the secret police chiefs the
secret police chiefs were always
pre-epic they
they could have any women they wanted
and they could also have access to any
amount of money they wanted so
there was a lot going a lot of partying
going on among these disgusting people
you say that yes off suffered constant
nervous illnesses
including sores and itchy skin tb angina
uh sciatica psoriasis a nervous
condition he probably shared with stalin
yeah and what they called and i can't
even pronounce this nourish
uh there's cenia urasthenia that was
just narcissina was just one of those
1930s diseases which you know
late victorian
diseases that went on until the second
world war just meant nervousness it was
an old-fashioned word we don't use it
anymore what happened to yazoo yes was
in the end arrested he got out of
control he started killing too many
people even for stalin and he he went he
was waiting he killed too many people
even for stalin yeah but you say
stalin might have killed 30 million
people yeah so so you can imagine what
an absolute psych psychopath this man
was jejov um he became an alcoholic you
see one of the things was one of the
things that i discovered in this book is
that these bolsheviks were often ill the
pressure of the work was amazing and
only stalin i mean even stalin suffered
from you know i discovered that he
suffered from sore throats and um and
skin problems and so on but the other
ones often just they just couldn't take
the pace of this incredible pressure and
stress and all night hard work
and the vast scale of work of building
the soviet union and they often got ill
they died of strokes and and they had
nervous illnesses and so on so that was
that was very much part of it and by the
way in these letters you know
they were building the soviet union they
were killing fat millions of people the
peasants were starving i've read all the
letters of the leaders among themselves
twenty percent of those letters i i
suspect were were really discussing
their health and they were enormous
hypochondriacs i mean in one sense they
were very ill but on the other sense it
was like a hypochondriac convention you
know they'd always be saying i've got
kidney stones how's your um how's your
shadow on your lung i've got a sore
throat you must try these new this new
spa i'm trying when they talked about it
the other 20 of their letters is all
about what holiday to take because they
were great holidays holidays were very
important right in the middle of the
terror right in the middle of the uh no
not so much actually the terror no one
went on a holiday but how long did that
last by the way the terror the terror
lasted for two years really 37 36 to 38.
and what was the total count of people
that were killed about a million
it was it was it was really against the
party the terror and it was really it
was it was really directed at their own
their own group their own people and
what they were basically doing was
extending their idea of the random
killing of classes to their own ruling
class and stalin reckoned they'd gone
soft and you see you've got to realize
that mustang stalin realized they
weren't subservient to these people a
lot of them had known him for 30 years
and they were over familiar with him
i found many letters where he wrote to
the provinces telling them to do
something they just ignored his letters
which is quite fascinating um they were
they they felt they knew him so well
that they could you know they weren't
afraid of him you know
he had a girlfriend i wanted his
mistress was his sister-in-law she um
her name her name yepgenia zhenya you
have jenny and there's a picture in the
book of uh and explain what that picture
is that's an amazing picture that i that
i discovered i mean you can imagine how
my heart was thrilled when i found that
picture um what it what it is is um
stalin surrounded by his women
essentially and it's a very informal
picture it was a birthday party in 1934
and sitting right between his legs
smiling like the cat that's got the
cream is his mistress
um
with the bible with the sort of she
always wore frilly these frilly colors
and that's his mistress and that's an
amazingly uninhibited picture isn't it
um
and um
and to her left to the right of her is
bronchophosgraphic
the the very pretty wife of his of his
chief of staff of his chef de cabinet
who um
who she was later shot by stalin and
she's a pretty girl as well
so fascinating picture
and that really is the court of the red
czar
um and well i i found that pictures
never been published before as far as i
know
and um
i was also able to find exactly who was
at that party what they were doing who
and what they said at the party
because we had the diaries of some of
the people one of the things that these
papers contain is the diaries of some of
the women at that in that group and
they've never been published before
either how about the photographs how
many other photographs uh here's one for
instance has this one been seen before
yeah that one has been seen before
um that one has that's a fascinating
picture that's stalin and barrier is the
mum with the round glasses and in the
foreground is his mother stalin's old
mother
then in her 80s
um
ill and about to die and mrs stalin's
last visit to her
and um
that's this is the famous time when they
had an amazing conversation
um stalin said to her um why did you
beat me so much as a child and his
mother said
um it was good for you you haven't
turned out so badly have you and then
his mother said to him
so joseph she called him so-so in fact
she said so
what do you do now what's your job now
and he said um remember the tsar and she
said yes and he and he said well i'm
something like the tsar and then she was
quite she smiled and she said
i think you'd have done better to become
a priest
as long as you're looking at photographs
what's this one right down here that's a
great picture that's stalin meeting some
um
some sort of female sugar beet
uh sugar beet farmers who've won a
record for for harvesting sugar beet and
the man with the the walrus moustache
behind
a little to stalin's right is marshall
padillani
um one of the great sort of military
heroes of the um of the regime
and a man who um and a man who uh didn't
think tanks would catch on he thought
that he said we don't need tanks horses
are much more important
and um luckily they didn't take his
advice otherwise they'd have lost the
second world war this is out of context
but uh the mount baton story yeah that's
fascinating isn't it i mean lord we know
lord mountbatten um
king george the sixth cousin later
viceroy um the last british viceroy of
india um remember the royal family um
he was um he wanted to meet stalin and
he went and um he went to potsdam where
stalin was to meet stalin and uh he
wanted to get in he wanted to basically
to drop he wanted to drop
that um his his grandfather or his or
his cousin or whatever was the last tsar
he was very closely related to the last
tsar and he'd visited the last czar
nicholas ii so mountbatten wanted to
tell star in this in the hopes of being
invited to um to visit the soviet union
and stalin um stalin was very
unimpressed with matt batten and he um
he said to him um
he said well i think it's changed a
little bit since you were last there he
said and mountbatten said well i was
related to the last so i visited often
it any chance i could visit again and
stalin just ignored this comment and
that's one of the stories that um that
is told here for the first time one of
the threads in the book is svetlana and
here she is about how old
um i'd say about um about 11 i think
or yeah
but there she's in her pioneers uniform
that's what every girl in the soviet
union wore and that scarf is a red scarf
of the young pioneer and this is a
photograph that's very typical of their
relationship as she began to grow up
um stalin began to um to clash swords
with her she was very strong she was
actually very like stalin himself
as a young girl
she was his absolute beloved favorite he
used to sign her homework like every
other parent in the soviet union would
sign their child's homework every
evening during the great terror he would
meet she would come to the kremlin to
their flat and he would check her
homework ask her how she did sit on she
would sit on his knee he'd feed her from
his own fork and um she'd write him
notes and he had this game with her
which i found all the notes that in the
archive that tell this story it's
absolutely amazing she would write notes
to her little secretaries stalin and
molotov and yes off and so on and she'd
say
you are ordered to cancel homework for
this year and the um in the soviet union
and delays the beginning of school by
two weeks signed the boss svetlana
and stalin she'd pin these she'd either
send them to stalin by aeroplane if he
was outside moscow or she'd pin them in
the diet to the board of the dining room
and stalin would pass these around at
the politburo and all the politburo
would sign we obey we've canceled school
this year signed your little secretary
style in a molotov so there's a lot of
sort of warm sort of games going on and
then as she got older and at the time of
that photograph that we've just shown
was taken
she began to become a woman and stalin
began to find this difficult to take and
when she sent him that picture he wrote
back a note saying
i don't like your your sort of bold ex
sort of bold almost sort of fearless
expression um because she was sort of
beginning to blossom as a woman as a
little little woman really and he found
that very difficult to take you told us
earlier that she now lives in wisconsin
yeah she lives now lives in wisconsin
and when you went to try to talk to her
who did you deal with to try to get to
her i knew people in england who knew
her and i asked them to write to her but
fortunately you know she's written two
biography two autobiographies splendid
books i mean she's a very intelligent
woman who's had a tragic life
i also had access to 10 hours of unused
tapes of her talking which someone in
england i found someone who had these
so i felt that you know her story was
actually quite well known and and though
i found out many new things about her
particularly her relationship with
berry's son
um
i um i didn't feel the i wanted i would
have seen her of course if i could have
um i tried and i and she wouldn't see me
but um frankly i you know i had so many
new people who no one had ever spoken to
before that i concentrated on that now
you've got two pictures up front uh the
one with her when she was about how old
was stalin um she must be about three or
four there i think or five but it's the
one below it they want to ask you about
yes now that is that is her with nadya
um that's her mother
um and there with her kind of
characteristic oval face her black hair
black eyes nadia alleluia everstar and
second wife who died tragically
committed suicide
and um of course the children never
quite recovered from her death
funny enough you know one of the ironies
i found out about this is that the
marriage between nadia and stalin is
normally spoken of as the sort of
sacrifice of this angelic girl and this
brutal ogre
true enough stalin wasn't ogre
but she was hardly she wasn't quite the
way we expect i mean she was she had um
these hysterical schizophrenic
interludes that were impossible for
stalin to to um
to deal with he just didn't he didn't
know how to handle her um she was very
puritanical humorless stalin had a much
you know it was a much warmer with the
children than her ironically and as she
got iller and more and these these these
psychological crises came about someone
said to her like you know you're all
right and she said no i just i just i
want to end it all and she they said
what about the children and she said i
don't even care about the children
anymore so
you know she was she was a very
difficult person to be married to i'm
not saying stalin wasn't absolutely
appalling personally married to
you have a picture of stalin in the
garden
yeah i mean in this book there's one set
of pictures that i think are the most
remarkable in the book which are
starling going camping starting
gardening conning starting shooting and
starting weeding his garden who's he
camping with here he's camping with
boris shiloff and marshall padillani you
know these pictures uh
as far as i know have never been seen
before and they're from stalin's own
private personal album who is he here
with at the bottom um that is going
shooting with marshall padiani and vora
shilov
who was vora shilov laura shiloff was
his um his his dandy-ish but brutal um
old friend a a lave turner turned
soldier who was um who was a hopeless
soldier in fact but um was one of his
closest closest stun people here's a
picture of kirov and you say that uh
he uh he lost his life yeah he was
assassinated in 1934. who was he he was
starting one of stalin's best friends he
was stalin was very attracted to these
kind of affable um he's affable bluff
um cheerful sort of people and kirov was
always singing opera to himself in fact
singing plays a huge part in this book
you know stalin was a great singer and
had a beautiful tenor voice
um
and they would always sing they would
actually even though they were arresting
priests killing priests they would they
would sing hymns together these people
you know why because they'd all been to
church school these people they were all
pre-trainee priests mikoyan you know
kidzi uh stalin were all trained as
priests at the seminary
and they used to sing hymns molotov who
was he dez molotov playing tennis
molotov was quite middle-class
um he was uh he was pretty humorous he
was one of those people in his office he
used to say i'm going to sleep for 13
minutes
and after 13 minutes he'd wake up you
know he was that
punctilious but he was absolutely brutal
he became foreign minister
and during the war years and made the
pact with ribbon trop but essentially
during the terror he was an absolute um
slaughterer and he often used to write
execute this person next to the wives of
people who were being arrested quite
unnecessarily
you know these people really are these
were diabolical people
and
the way they killed the enthusiasm with
which they killed
is part of this story
and it's it's funny when sort of you
know i was kind of reading their love
letters one day and their death lists
the next day and i guess that's what
this book is about and one hand i was
finding out what they ate what they sung
who they made love to how they wrote
love letters where they went on holiday
and their illnesses and so on the next
time i was talking about like how they
had vendettas against their enemies how
they believed in killing enormous
numbers of people at random
um how they visited torture chambers
and how they suggested more and more
people should be thrown into this meat
grinder of death
how much of this did we know
we knew the big picture now this is this
book is this book is an intimate private
the private world this is the intimate
portrait of stalin in his inner circle
which has never been really written
before we knew we already knew about the
terror we already knew about the war we
already knew about industrialization and
did we know that during the war when we
were going to potsdam and and tehran and
uh you know we knew we always we always
knew about august killing don't let
anyone tell you they didn't know they
knew about it everyone knew about it um
and um in the west
just people just chose to to ignore it i
mean for example the biggest imbecile of
the lot was the american ambassador to
moscow joseph davis whose memoirs were
later made into a movie mission to
moscow which you might have seen but you
know during the show trials the stalin's
trials of his enemy which were
completely clearly faked completely
ludicrous
where you had these people who've been
tortured speaking like automatons and
confessing to all sorts of absurd
terrorist activities
ambassador davis was was um telegraphing
president roosevelt that these were abs
as a lawyer he said these are absolutely
legalistically um watertight he said you
know
so you there were some very stupid
people and there were a lot of willful
people who just chose to ignore this
absolute this absolute chronicle of
murder and slaughter what's the story of
kulik's wife kira now that's a
fascinating story kulix white cool it
was marshall kulik was it was a top
soviet general one of stalin's old
drinking buddies
um kira kulik was a countess a
account's daughter an ex-aristocrat she
was the most beautiful girl in stalin's
circle and a great flirt with stalin too
but she made the mistake of asking
stalin to intercede for her brother who
in fact had already been shot
and she also flirted too much and talked
too much and kulik talked too much about
the terror so stalin and barrier when
they were when they were running the
terror they like to devise these kind of
these kind of gangster-ish brigand-like
kidnappings so stalin said to barrier
kidnap the wife kira and we'll deal with
her and meanwhile on the same day he
promoted general kulick to marshall
so on the very day that he was promoted
to marshall
marshall kulik lost his wife so he went
to bury her and said where's my wife
and barrier knew that kulik's wife kira
was in the cellars underneath his office
but he pretended kulik was in his office
taking tea he pretended to ring stalin
and he said oh
stalin um it's barry here
where is my i've got marshall kunich in
my office his wife's gone missing do we
know where he where she is
no said stalin
harry puts telephone we've got no idea
where she is we'll search the whole
soviet union for her meanwhile
this girl who was just beautiful girl
innocent of anything
you know beautifully dressed slim
is literally just shot in the head
on their orders down under you know in
these in these dungeons underneath this
place and marshall kulik accepts this he
knows after a bit that she's disappeared
and he marries again
these were really disgusting people did
you go to libyan
prison yeah i did go there what is it
it's a huge um it's a huge office
complex built of granite where on
lubianca square in moscow which is a
huge um huge square not near about a
couple of miles from the kremlin and
um underneath it as large as the sort of
bit above it which is huge underneath it
is a huge um rabbit war and a beehive of
of um of dungeons and one of the
interesting things was that yezhov the
poison dwarf that we've talked about he
um
he devised the idea like what he thought
was the ideal execution cell under there
and what it was was it had a sloping
floor for bodily fluids it had wooden
walls and it had it had done hosing
facilities so you could just kill people
at a great rate in there of course the
irony was that when he was arrested
um and shot he himself was shot in his
own the own the special execution room
that he he'd done he'd created
perhaps there's some justice in that
after you uh had gathered all your
material yeah and wrote your book yeah
and it was published in in england when
um about a year ago
has there been new stuff since then that
you really wanted to have in here no you
know what there hasn't really um i've
been i was just really fortunate that
this was the biggest amount of new stuff
i mean this is based on such a massive
archive of new materials and they and
the nice exciting thing about it is not
only is it absolutely fascinating um you
know in in terms of its depravity and
its private details it's i mean many of
these letters for example are very funny
um some are very tragic they're people
begging stalin for his life some are
very very intimate as i mentioned his
love letters and so on um
summer where he passes around he draws
pictures and passes around the politburo
table but the great thing also is that
on serious political terms this changes
the way that we write about stalin's
rule because it shows that he became
dictator much later and it shows how he
built his rule by you know the way most
machine politicians build their rule by
showing
favors to people by being kind to people
by arranging well one of the first
documents i found was a list of cars and
of course you know these people all had
buicks and packards american cars and
cadillac and cadillacs and rolls-royces
could have some english ones in there
too and i found this list it was in
stalin's handwriting and i gradually
realized that stalin himself
every year would assign which family the
molotovs you have two buicks and a
cadillac you know the kanganovich is you
can have a cadillac and two packards and
he did this himself i mean when berry
the personal care he took of these
people is amazing when berrien moved to
moscow
arrived in moscow start and found his
house arranged his removals personally
when barry's wife didn't like her house
he found her another house himself he
tucked in barriers ten-year-old son into
bed read stories to him
um it's just the book is just full of
the sort of style and taking this sort
of care with people
um
you know the irony that all this is he
may have been a monster he may have
lacked empathy stalin was one of the
great people managers people persons if
you like
how does this book sell in great britain
it's it's really so i mean there are now
50 000 of these
in hardback in great britain which is
which is a lot how about in the united
states well it's just come out of the
united states so but it's selling or
it's already gone into a second edition
they've they've reprinted it so i'm very
excited i mean the reviews have been
marvelous i'm very i'm just thrilled
about it actually it's very exciting do
you have any advice for somebody and as
i said earlier it's hard to keep track
as you know all these people yes what
advice would you give people on how to
deal with a book like this it's 800
pages
my advice is just to my advice is
twofold i mean um to read to take the
information about the soviet regime to
heart
the warning from history about how
about how this is what happens when
religious maniacs and fanatics have
unlimited violence and that becomes
their normal way of governing
on the other hand this is a personal
history about love and fear and murder
and killing
and betrayal
and so this book can be read either as a
very serious work of scholarship or it
can be read as like a sort of russian
version of the godfather
and you know there are a lot of foreign
names in there it doesn't matter is
there a movie in this
i think there'd be a great movie in
there i think it would be like i
claudius it would like like a sort of
band of brothers meets like claudius you
know th
i mean basically the personal details in
this
fascinated me i mean i was i was shocked
by so many things i mean stalin the
intellectual stalin's reading for
example his habits just fascinated me
and i went through his library and
everything what do you read he read one
of his favorite books was last of the
mohicans
and he used mark cooper yeah
well it was an acceptable book for the
soviets of course because it was it was
all about sort of included british
imperialists behaving appallingly and um
and white and white people behaving
badly to to native native indians where
is his book where are his books they're
all in this archive too and i got out
piles of them and again you can sort of
i could smell the um the pipe smoke in
them and he and also he annotated them
all the time with his own margin
comments sometimes he just put hahaha
beside places in the book which is
sinister
but he really he read a lot
he knew
he knew balzac he knew zola he read
goethe um
he read books of american history
you know he he read books about british
history when he was meeting churchill he
read about the duke of mauber a
churchill's ancestor so when he met
church he was able to charm churchill by
saying by the way he was teasing him you
see he said by the way the duke of
wellington is a much greater man than
the duke of marlborough do you speak
english no not really he could he
claimed to be able to look at recognize
some words i didn't think he could you
mentioned the pipe and you could tell
according to what you've written here
what kind of a mood he was in on whether
the pipe was lit or was not yeah if it
was unlit you could be if it was just
left unlit and he was just chewing it
nervously you could be in big trouble i
mean dealing with stalin was like in the
end you had to learn how to deal with
this terrifying man and dealing with
them was a bit like those instructions
that they give to to campers about what
to do if a bear comes into your tent but
he could be charming to people i mean
one of the fascinating people i met was
a guy who at 25 called alec troyonovsky
whose father was the first ambassador to
america of the soviet union
he went down to do some interpreting for
stalin and at the end of the
interpreting the guests left and stalin
said to him he was about 25 he said
hey why don't you stay with me um for a
week and he said you know what we'll do
he said we'll get you drunk and see what
kind of person you are so this poor boy
of 25 stayed with stalin for a week and
this story has never really been told
but i went to met who's just died trying
off how was how old was he i know he
must have been 80 or something it was a
marvelous night i can't believe he died
because he died soon after i'd you know
written the published the book but he
basically told me the story of how um
how stalin has stayed at stalin for a
week and it is extraordinary you know he
said that stalin he'd have dinner with
stalin he was very careful not to sort
of say anything that would he knew his
father had known stalin very well so he
was very he was a very savvy person
and stalin told him stories from his
youth stalin once said
um i once stood next he said we know
when i was staying with your parents in
vienna starting went to vienna in 1913
and he stayed with tronowski's father
and he told him this story he said you
know when i was staying with your father
in 1913
i wanted to see
if a child could be weaned off its
parents
um so you see what i did was i gave your
sister sweets every day
and after the end of the fifth day
um
your mother and i stood and we called
your sister and he said she came to me
because she wanted the sweets
it was a very interesting story stalin
told him that himself which stalin's
real name um drugashvili joseph jude
philly where do you get the name stalin
he made it up he was the ultimate
self-made man he believed himself as a
sort of messianic character special
a marxist messiah mean anything man of
steel man of steel but they all adopted
names that meant things i mean molotov
means um hammer the man hannah person
that's not his real name
scoria bin is his real name
and um
and canada about malinka milankov's real
name i mean the ones who were
underground revolutionaries all had many
names nom de gea you know sort of names
names of the revolutionary movement but
once the revolution happened they didn't
need to change them anymore but stalin
once lost his temper with his son vasily
the crown prince is spoiled
pathetic son
who said but i he was throwing his
weight around and in fact in the book
one of the fascinating things we have
all his letters
we all vaccinate stalin's letters to his
guards and he was always writing to them
ordering them to do things and um
one of the things he said was he said
i'm stalin he said i'm vasily stalin
stalin said no you're not he said
you're not stalin i'm not stalin he said
stalin is soviet power stalin is what's
in the newspapers stalin is the image of
the soviet union not even i am stalin
very interesting sort of um esoteric
point there
stalin was making one time i was
interviewing a fellow in moscow on by
phone within the last year and he was
one maybe the moscow state news or
something and i just asked him the last
question uh who in history do you admire
and he said
marshall zhukov yeah martial zhukov the
real the greatest soldier of the second
world war were you right there's an
incident uh about marshall zhukov um
that i want to ask you about when he
broke down and cried yeah and so and
stalin's presence one of the really
exciting things um one of the really
exciting things at the moment is that
the materials i have now i could talk a
lot more about how the world world war
two
how stalin was commander in chief how he
functioned as commander and what really
happened in the early days of the war
let me just show a picture first the
picture on the screen is where is zhukov
jukov is on the left as you look at it
on stalin's right in other words um
who are the other two the other two are
um marshall vorishilov useless um
political general who i mentioned was
was a great dandy and on on on the far
right as we look at it is marshall pogan
and another political general so typical
stalin on one side he's got these
useless political generals and on one
side he's got the greatest general of
the second world war the man who won
stalingrad the battle of moscow the
battle of berlin saved the save the
siege of leningrad i mean forget armor
general montgomery or your eisenhower i
mean zhukov was far and away the
greatest general he why he won all the
decisive battles of the second world war
he saved moscow he saved leningrad he
helped devise
uh the battle of stalingrad he took
berlin
pretty unbelievable so when did he break
down and cry
the first few days the war was
fascinating stalin had got it really
wrong
and um
he'd misunderstood hitler what year this
is
1939-41 those two years started made a
pact with hitler to divvy up europe
basically between them and they cut
poland in half
fascinating thing is people said why did
he misunderstand hitler did he admire
hitler well he he misunderstood hitler
for this reason and there's a
fascinating thing i found in georgia a
bit of paper that explained this a story
that's of someone who was with started
when he was reminiscing after war on the
only time he ever discussed how he got
it wrong and what he said was my big
mistake was to put myself in hitler's
place
to imagine the hitler was like me in
other words stalin was a cautious
statesman um hitler was a gambler a
sleepwalker as hitler called it that was
his big mistake he thought that's why he
thought hitler wouldn't wouldn't invade
or would invade later now
when the war started hit stalin was
humiliated caught unawares
and at first of all though he thought
that it was fine he could the red army
would defeat the um the invasion
and then suddenly minsk fell after about
a week since the opening of operation
barbarossa stalin where's matt minsk is
on the road to moscow it's in bella
russia now but it's a big city and it
you know it's far as deep in the soviet
union and when that when minsk fell
stalin suddenly realized he was in big
trouble and the whole thing had
collapsed so he went to see his chief of
staff with all his barrier and him and
and molotov went to see um i went to see
marshall zhukov then general zhukov and
and when they said where the heck what's
he said what the hell is going on zhukov
where are the armies
what's happened to mints because it
fallen or hasn't it
and zhukov just said we don't know and
zhukov you've got to rush is the
toughest most ruthless general i mean he
was as ruthless as stalin he didn't care
how many losses he had a great general
but you know his bruce his brutality is
often underestimated he didn't he was he
would clear minefields by making people
run across them so at this point so bad
was the crisis that zhukov actually
burst into tears and ran out of the room
molotov another brutal man followed him
out and led him his handkerchief and
when they came back in stalin famously
realized that he was he was in trouble
and he'd blown it and he said we've
screwed up we've lost everything lenin
built he then went to his dacha his
country house shut himself in and
abandoned command and abandoned russia
to it and he had basically had some sort
of breakdown
no one could reach him for three days
it's a fascinating moment in the history
of in the history of the second world
war
you uh right about
the little corner the little corner
where is it it's in the yellow palace
it's still the place where the soviet
union is ruled from funnily enough that
the rooms where stalin ruled um the
little corners it was called are
where lenin ruled and where putin rules
today and of course putin has a special
connection to stalin when putin's
grandfather was stalin's cook
and um
you know which is just one of those
another sort of just gripping detail
isn't it i mean putin's grandfather
served as a waiter rasputin
was an under chef for lenin in lenin's
kitchen and then was started one of
stalin's chief cooks which is
amazing exam he must be the most world
historical cook in all of history
when they you said that the polar bureau
lived together yeah
and they visited all the time yeah who
were the ones that were the the name the
ones that were the closest to stalin and
they were in and out of his apartment it
was an apartment yeah they live in these
apartments they live basically in two
buildings in the kremlin which one of
which you can still see have you been
there by the way i haven't been in there
but i've seen it i've been you can't
actually go in there um they're not very
keen to let you see sort of stalin's
flats and stuff you know apart from the
fact that they're now the offices are
now used by the president of russia but
they had such a world of intimacy it was
almost like a university where you'd go
and borrow sugar from the people next
door you know they would be um there
would be kaganovich molotov mikhoyan um
uh these people yellow kidzi these
people would pop in on each other
andreas they would pop in and shovel all
the time their children played together
stalin played with their children i mean
i've spoken to many people who played as
stalin stalin was very good with the
children he used to he used to say what
should we do nash we throw should we
fray our should we take the cork from
the bottle of wine and throw it into the
ice cream and he'd throw it down they'd
have competitions throwing it down the
table he's very sweet to children and
one of the children used to play them
and said the great thing about him was
we loved talking to him because
he would talk to us like we were adults
and listen to what we said
there's a very he was a bundle of
contradictions and that's what this book
is about this book is about how like
he wasn't when one comes across true
evil it's not going to appear
um wearing as a grotesque it's going to
appear as someone one trust someone
normal someone charming
could you conclude after all this that
they were mentally ill it's too easy to
conclude that i mean we've just got away
for far too long we're saying hitler and
stalin killed 30 million people each
there's they were just
it's that's a cop-out for us as a
historian we've got to answer how it
worked what really happened
and and and also give the warning from
history and what really happened was
that there were millions of murderers in
stalin's russia and that stalin was
surrounded by people and actually often
the wives the women were the worst they
were the most brutal they were the ones
who were having these witch hunts
pointing at people and saying that's an
enemy of the people i've seen in his
eyes um
you know there were lots of killers
around stalin they were all believed in
this marxist bolshevik idea
of killing enemies killing vast classes
at random
that was the bolshevik way that's what
this book is about stalin this is a an
intimate private picture of stalin as
man and monster
you tell the story that in 1943 he
wanted to pay for lodging
at some occasion and
he looked for money and he had never he
never spent a dime yeah or a kopec since
1917. that's right because of course
he'd been in the state machinery and
they they never paid for anything they
had their own they had these amazing
cars pack hard cars they had special
shops
they received food i mean one of the
most hilarious um one of the most
hilarious things i found was from his
wife nadia to the head of state
um from mrs stalin to the head of state
and it said dear comrade kalinin
stalin must have his chickens
stalin is on a chicken diet
um stalin has been assigned 15 chickens
but he's already eaten seven stalin
cannot run out of chickens he must have
roast chicken please send us more
chickens signed nadia stalin which gives
you an idea just a little glimpse of
ordinary life these top leaders were all
involved in
the good life the houses they had the
holidays um what food they at um they
were given wads of money which were
called pacquiao
packets you know basically money in a
brown envelope cash
and all of this was supervised by stalin
himself he took enormous interest in
everything what's next for you well i
think i'm going to go back i mean i
think i i'm very tempted to write about
stalin more i mean you know this book it
covers him his reign of his reign of
power his reign of fear and um but i i i
there are large parts that i haven't
written that he's younger younger style
and stalin and lenin would be an
interesting book to do break down the
name simon seabag montefiore where do
they come from well simon's a good old
fashioned english name seabag montefury
is a i'm i'm i'm a sort of jewish
mongrel i mean my mother's family come
from russia hence my interest in russia
they come from poland and ukraine and so
on like many people here um
the montefiore sebage modifier is a
sephardic jewish which means from the
arab world or the mediterranean the
montefiores are italians
and the seabags or the sebas are
moroccans arab jews so i'm a jewish
mongrel very proud of it too
and if you're going to do more on stalin
is are there more archives to read i
don't know there may be closing and
opening i mean this was just such a
great opportunity i was so lucky to be
able to write this book and that's why i
worked so hard and got it out as quick
as possible because i knew that it was
just a one-off opportunity when would
you like to do this next book
i'm having a rest this year i'm on tour
in america and then in sweden and
holland and then it's coming out in
paperback in in in england so i've got
i'm i'm still i'm still living at the
course of the red czar
we're out of time stalin the court of
the red czar
simon seabag monteviori thank you very
much thank you so much
[Music]
for a dvd or videotape call 1877
on c-span for a free transcript or to
learn more about booknotes visit us at
booknotes.org
next week on book notes alan brodsky
author of benjamin rush patriot and
physician
book notes can be seen every sunday on
c-span at 8 pm eastern and 8 p.m pacific
time
go to booknotes.org to watch both parts
of our conversation with simon seabag
montefiore